[Musik]
zwei Mädchen niedergestochen auf dem Weg
zur Schule ihr Angreifer ein
geflüchteter aus Eritrea der Mord in
Illerkirchberg wühlt Deutschland auf
jetzt wurde der 27-Jährige Täter zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt
dezember 2022 im beschaulichen
Illerkirchberg nahe Ulm macht sich die
14-Jährige ätsche mit ihrer Freundin auf
den Weg zum Schulbus gefolgt vom Blick
der Mutter ihr Bruder hat den früheren
Bus genommen die beiden Mädchen gehen
wie jeden Tag an der
Flüchtlingsunterkunft vorbei plötzlich
läuft ein Mann auf sie zu grüßt kurz und
sticht dann völlig unvermittelt auf die
beiden ein die 13-Jährige kann nach dem
ersten Stich flüchten daraufhin
attackiert der Mann ECE mit dem Messer
sticht mehrmals von hinten auf sie ein
dann läuft er weg waren reine
Zufallsopfer man kann tatsächlich sagen
die beiden Mädchen waren an diesem Tag
zur falschen Zeit im falschen Ort
er habe gedacht die Mädchen hätten sein
Messer bemerkt sagt der Mann aus Eritrea
später in der Vernehmung aus das Motiv
war zunächst angeklagt dass er zum
Landratsamt gehen wollte um einen Pass
zu erpressen das hat sich jetzt insofern
geändert dass das die Kamera das
anderswürdig die Kamera hat so gesehen
dass da Angeklagte vor hatte hier Rache
zu üben an dem Landratsamt donaukreis
das ihm sein Leben zerstört hat und da
wiederum die Mädchen dazwischen gekreuzt
sind
nach der Tat bleibt ethisch schwer
verletzt am Boden liegen ihre ebenfalls
verletzte Freundin ruft um Hilfe doch
die Rettungskräfte können ethische nicht
reanimieren sie stirbt in der Klinik an
den tiefen Stichwunden
was macht diese Tat mit
Iller Kirchberg zwei Monate nach der
Messerattacke treffen wir kreisrad
mashallah domlu er erzählt wie der Mord
politisch instrumentalisiert wurde wie
sie spontan rechtsradikale unter die
Trauernden mischen Ausländer Hass
schüren die ersten Tagen waren
extremst hart hinten am Tatort waren
sehr schnell sehr viele Menschen
zusammengestanden verschiedene Menschen
mit rechte Gesinnung linke Gesinnung und
was sehr Angst gemacht hat war eben mit
diesen auf scheiß verbrennt sie und
abschieben und Todesstrafe und so weiter
das hat mir sehr Angst gemacht in den
ersten Tagen
bin aber sehr froh dass Iller Kirchberg
zusammen stand
er hatten die Größe in einem offenen
Brief vor Hass und Hetze zur warnen auch
ihnen schulde man Aufarbeitung die
Probleme müssen auf den Tisch wie kann
es sein dass Menschen die zu uns
geflüchtet sind die wir ja aufnehmen und
unsere
Gastfreundschaftlichkeit zeigen dass man
auch wissen wie sie ticken es würde ja
schon sehr gut tun wenn man
professionelle Unterstützung hätte in
Form von Sozialarbeitern da ist die eine
Frage die in Iller Kirchberg wieder laut
wird werden geflüchtete eher straffällig
die Zahl Tatverdächtiger Zuwanderer ist
2022 im Vergleich zum Vorjahr nur leicht
gestiegen mit 7,6% sind sie trotzdem
überproportional vertreten bei
Verbrechen gegen das Leben sechsmal so
auffällig wie deutsche die Täter
hauptsächlich jung und männlich aber
unter geflüchteten sind eben auch
besonders viele junge Männer Rainer
frohenmöller ist flüchtlingshelfer in
Illerkirchberg die Tat ist für ihn ein
Schlag ins Gesicht
trifft ein extrem also ich wusste nicht
welche Gedanken ich nach dieser
mortart aufnehmen sollte und und hier
war bestürzt weil man versucht hat hier
wirklich es gut zu machen in der
Integration das dann so eine Tat
passiert war ich sag mal war für unsere
integrationsarbeiter der Supergau und
daher macht man sich natürlich Gedanken
hätte man noch was besser machen können
bzw wie hätten wir mit umgehen können
und darum dreht sich sehr viel der Täter
wirkte auf Sie ruhig eher introvertiert
aber selbst wenn sie waren Zeichen
bemerkt hätten da sind kaum
Therapieplätze um zu reagieren die
Betreuung geflüchteter lastet
hauptsächlich auf den Schultern der
Ehrenamtlichen wir halten hier die
Flüchtlinge zur Aufnahme und erfahren
grundsätzlich nichts über die Person wir
haben nur die Unterbringung zu regeln
und das halte ich für nicht gut wenn man
jemand helfen möchte ist es immer
wichtig zu wissen was ist das für ein
Mensch und was hat er für einen
Hintergrund die flüchtlingshelfer und
der Bürgermeister werden bedroht die
Gemeinde überfordert der Bürgermeister
zieht sich aus der Öffentlichkeit zurück
der hat immer wieder betont dass es ihm
ganz wichtig ist dass man trotzdem
zusammenhält und dass man halt nicht
jetzt pauschal geflüchtete
vorverurteilt oder gegen geflüchtete
Herz Bürgerdialog im Januar die Behörden
wollen den Einwohnern die Möglichkeit
geben über ihre Gefühle zu sprechen da
ist Wut Angst Unsicherheit
ich war ich habe das aber nicht so
gesehen weil da an das Haus da
schlimm
aus Sorge vor radikalen Kräften dürfen
nur Bewohner in die Mehrzweckhalle auch
unsere Kamera muss draußen bleiben nicht
das erste Mal halte es uns entgegen 2019
hat im Ort eine Gruppe geflüchteter ein
Mädchen vergewaltigt ein Täter wurde
nach seiner Haft wieder hier
untergebracht das macht was mit den
Leuten ist doch klar
und ich verstehe nach wie vor nicht wenn
ich sage mal wenn ich jetzt in Syrien
oder wo auch immer so was machen würde
was die mit der machen würden
aber es ist natürlich immer möglich sage
wenn solche Flüchtlinge kommen die hier
eine ganz andere ganz andere Bezug und
ganz an der Mentalität das ist aber
tiefe irgendwo Enttäuschung man hat sich
von kleinen obwohl gefühlt im Dorf so
geborgen und das so was passieren kann
was hat den Täter bewogen vom Prozess
erhoffen sich die Menschen Antworten
lokaljournalistin Julia Horn hat über
die Tat und ihre Folgen berichtet sie
begleitet auch den Gerichtsprozess für
ihre Zeitung das öffentliche Interesse
und die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind
groß als der Täter am 2 juni vor Gericht
gestellt wird
es war einfach hoch emotional von Anfang
an also ab dem ersten Prozesstag man hat
den gerade den Vertretern der Familien
also die nebenklagevertretern einfach
angemerkt wie involviert sie sind und
wie schwer es den auch fällt ja zum
Beispiel ihre Plädoyers zu halten der
geflüchtete aus Eritrea ist geständig
will im Prozess aber nicht aussagen ein
Dolmetscher übersetzt für ihn die Eltern
bei der Mädchen werden von Anwälten als
Nebenkläger vertreten ich habe Kinder im
selben Alter ungefähr die gehen auf
dieselbe Schule deswegen war es sehr gut
die verletzte 13-jährige hat für den
Prozess einen Brief geschrieben die
Anwältin der Familie hat die Worte dann
vorgelesen und es war auch ein ja sehr
bewegend sie hat unter anderem
geschrieben das ätsche einfach Ihre
allerbeste Freundin war und dass sie in
ganz toller Mensch war und dass sie sehr
dankbar ist dass findet ihr befreundet
sein konnte und das war wirklich ein
Moment wo man dann auch gemerkt hat das
ist allen gerade nahe geht im Gericht
viele Fragen bleiben offen auch nachdem
der Richter in Ulm sein Urteil verkündet
hat lebenslang mit besonderer Schwere
der Schuld für den geflüchteten aus
Eritrea er wollte töten so der Richter
als ihm die Mädchen zufällig über den
Weg laufen war das maximale was das
Gericht aussprechen konnte und das hat
auch gemacht und deswegen sind wir
zufrieden juristischen Sinne bedeutet
lebenslang plus die besondere Schwere
der Schuld dass eine Entlassung nach 15
Jahren erstmal unmöglich ist
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich so dass
er sich mit Abschiebung einverstanden
erklärt hat und nach Eritrea zurück
möchte
es wird nicht seine Entscheidung sein
wann das der Fall ist und in welche Form
auch wenn der 27-Jährige jetzt
lebenslang ins Gefängnis muss für ihrer
Kirchberg setzt das Urteil keinen
Schlusspunkt der Prozess war so tragisch
weil einfach auch diese
Frage nach dem Warum nicht beantwortet
wurde also
bis jetzt gibt es ja keine plausible
Erklärung dafür was ein quasi passiert
ist und es wird wahrscheinlich auch
nicht geben und das ist das was halt
bleibt also das ist der Eindruck der
bleibt das eben die Antworten nicht
gekommen sind die sich wahrscheinlich
auch die Familien erhofft haben um halt
mit dem ganzen abzuschließen der
eritreische Mitbewohner des Täters hat
sich nach dem Mord das Leben genommen
die Unterkunft Sinnbild zweier Tragödien
ages Eltern haben sich gewünscht dass
das Gebäude abgerissen wird das ist
mittlerweile passiert aber es ist
wichtig die Tat nicht zu verdrängen
sondern daraus zu lernen findet
werden unabhängig von vom Prozess
Prozess ist die juristische Seite was ja
ein Muss ist und wir haben das unser
Vertrauen in die Justiz nur
wie das aufgearbeitet wird und wie man
hier vor Ort dann mit solchen
geflüchteten umgeht und damit die Angst
weg ist muss man eben wieder Vertrauen
schaffen und Vertrauen werden wir
höchstwahrscheinlich nur mit eben
professionelle Hilfe schaffen die
Betroffenheit ist immer noch da wir sind
aber froh dass das Haus mal weg ist und
vielleicht trägt es eben etwas wieder
zur Ruhe bei nicht Hass und Hetze sollen
wachsen sondern eine Wiese für alle
Kinder des Ortes und Ates Geschwister
[Musik]